bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce 78
weekend alors vous connaissez le
principe de cette émission durant ce
journal nous allons revenir sur
l'actualité de la semaine et vous donner
des idées de sortie pour le weekend dans
cette émission nous recevrons aussi deux
invités Maxime l'épicier et runau de la
ville brune avec eux nous parlerons
automobiles anciennes puisqu'ils
organisent ce weekend de rally de
vieilles voitures où jeunes et moins
jeunes se réunissent autour de la même
passion on en parle tout à l'heure mais
tout de suite une question que tous les
lycéens se posent que faire après le bac
pour tenter de répondre à cette question
le label des cordés de la réussite mise
en place dès 2008 par l'État propose aux
jeunes des rencontr dans dans des
instituts d'enseignement supérieur
l'occasion pour les élèves d'élargir
leurs horizons comme ici à 3IS l'école
des métiers du cinéma d'élencour
Jonathan villman pour les
images découvrir de nouveaux métier pour
élargir ses perspectives d'avenir c'est
ce que propose tout au long de l'année
le label des cordés de la réussite en
organisant des ateliers rencontres entre
collégiens lycéen et institut
d'enseignement supérieur ainsi vendredi
dernier une centaine d'élèves se
rendaient à l'Institut imagés son 3isè
d'lancour l'occasion pour eux de
découvrir les métiers du cinéma de
l'audiovisuel du Journ
ou encore du spectacle vivant et même de
s'improviser perchiste l'idée c'est de
les mettre en situation je leur mets un
micro une perche et puis il se POS des
questions entre eux ils échangent ils
appréhendent du coup le son de cette
manière là de leur montrer que ce qu'ils
apprennent à l'école ça peut leur ouvrir
des portes pour plein de choses qu'ils
imaginent pas forcément en l'occurrence
les métiers du cinéma c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on qui paraî accessible tout de
suite pour quand on est au lycée au
collège et bah là de voir ça et de
l'appréender ça peut donner envie
d'aller voir autre chose quoi donc se
montrer d'ouvrir les horizons autre
atelier découverte organisé le studio
radio reçu par deux animateurs étudiants
3IS les lycéens ont pu s'initier à
l'exercice journalistique je savais pas
que c'était aussi compliqué de lancer un
débat de pouvoir avoir des de la
répartie de poser les questions quand il
y a des blancs ça m'intéresse bien
d'aller vers euh ces milieux-là et oui
aussi il y a des camarades qui sont avec
moi qui sont bien intéressés aussi par
euh par tout ça par l'audiovisuel
institution les rêves prennent forme
mais les formations coûtent toujours
cher pour des élèves issus de milieu
modeste à 3IS il faut débourser pas
moins de 7000 € pour une année
d'enseignement l'établissement privé
tente néanmoins de trouver un accord
avec les collectivités pour recevoir des
étudiants
boursiers découvrir de nou lire à voix
haute un art à partentière qu'il faut
savoir maîtriser à bois d'Arc la
médiathèque de la tremblée propose des
stages de lecture à voie haute justement
l'occasion pour certains de gagner en
confiance lors d'une prise de parole en
public yolen Torres et Elod Mo j'ai
tellement peur de rater le train que
j'arrive à la gare avec TR quheure
d'avance et je qu'estce qu'elle croyait
la
Paris accélérer le rythme le ralentir
autant d'exercice qui permettent de
gagner en assurance pour lire à voix
haute et devant tout type de public pour
3e année consécutive à Bois d'Arcy la
médiathèque de la tremblée propose des
stages de lecture sur un weekend on
découvre les mots on comprend d'une sens
on le met en place plus on ralentit plus
on articule donc voilà l'exercice mais
et la vitesse
amène une assurance une une vitalité au
texte l'histoire se construit donc la
pant de la lenteur c'est que on donne le
temps
mettre les voix sont différentes les les
forces de voix aussi les volumes de voix
donc du coup il faut jongler avec ça
surtout quand on lit à plusieurs arriver
à ce qu'une vois n'écrase pas une autre
que voilà c'est surtout làdessus qu'on
travaille là quand on est en groupe
habitué à parler en public lors de ses
cours de théâtre Nicole s'est tout de
même senti déstabilisé par les exercices
ce stage c'est aussi pourelle l'occasion
de découvrir des
histoires personnellement j'ai découvert
un texte magnifique que je ne
connaissais pas donc il a déjà eu le le
le plaisir le bonheur de la découverte
et effectivement les mots prennent un
sens différent presque différent de
quand on lit pour soi en fait lecteur
contteur et comédien Rémy profite de ce
stage pour se perfectionner on
a tendance à à vouloir rester sur son
propre rythme
et je crois quand même que la lecture la
plus lente est
plus compliqué à maîtriser oui on se
concentre plus sur le mot en lui-même
que sur la phrase dans sa
totalité prochaine session prévu le
weekend des 1ers de février de séances
de 3h sont proposé pour 35 € onaccuse de
cruauté c'est moi tout CCH ça c'est
bizarre onait pas vu un chat de la
matinée et vers 1h de l'après-midi le
défil commence qu'est-ce qu' croyait la
Parisienne on est arrivé qu' Fabien
et on reste sur scène avec bazar et
bémol un trio originaire des Yvelines
qui sera sur scène justement le 25
janvier à la batterie de Guy en courour
nous les avons rencontré au cours de
leur résidence artistique qui précède le
concert Aurélia debissi et Étienne
Dang venez faireiller votre Ferrari de
notre casserole venez faire danser vos
oreilles cabriole chash nine et Raphaël
trois musiciens talentueux trois amis
aussi qui depuis 6 ans forment le groupe
bazar et bémol leurs études achevées fin
2010 ils décident de faire de la musique
une activité professionnelle de la
chanson française swing teintée de
multiples influences du coup tout
l'intérêt pour nous c'est de sortir de
des clichés de la chanson française pour
essayer de faire quelque chose un peu
voilà métisser avec d'autres styles une
vraie complémentarité entre chacun tant
dans la composition que dans l'écriture
des textes une plume soignée que manie
avec énergie et humour ce trio
festif pour blchir V
lingez on écrit tous les trois et mais
onécrit pas ensemble puis après on fait
les arrangements ensemble et le texte
quand en tout cas à la phase d'écriture
le texte est très important on écrit
juste texte et la mélodie est là pour
mettre en avant le texte et voilà c'est
pour ça qu'il y a un travail d'écriture
très important sur la forme des mots
qu'on va utiliser on veut que ce soit le
plus poétique possible leurs premières
scènes ont lieu dans les rames du métro
parisien puis de place publique en
cabaret la mise en scène du spectacle
prend une nouvelle dimension une
transition s'opère un changement
d'échelle qui nécessite de porter un
nouveau regard sur le show après un
travail de résidence avec les studios de
la batterie à guillancour ils se
produiront sur scène le 25 janvier la
résidence c'est c'est assez intense
parce que c'est sur 3 jours 3 4 jours on
est vraiment tous les jours à avoir
beaucoup beaucoup d'idées et comme Alex
Christophe et Fab nous le disent
régulièrement c'est que voilà nous on
vous donne des idées vous les prenez
vous les mettez en place et puis après
vous vous réfléchissez et vous vous
prenez celle là vous prenez C là vous
éjectez C et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant en fait c'est de recevoir
cet afflux d'information en plus d'un
autre regard que notre m en scène
habituelle et trier et voir qu'est-ce
qui peut être le mieux dans notre
spectacle quoi la sortie de leur premier
album est prévu pour début
2015 on reste sur le thème de la culture
jusqu'au 2 mars la ville de en cours
propose de découvrir 60 années
d'évolution des œuvres de Gérard Manoni
un artiste sculpteur qui réalisa
d'ailleurs pour la ville en 84 la place
Jacques Brell au quartier d'garen
Aurélia debissi et elodim
moine la salle d'exposition de
guillancour accueille jusqu'au 2 mars
une rétrospective des œuvres du
sculpteur Gérard Manoni en accord avec
son époque l'artiste s'imprègne des
évolutions techniques esthétiques et
sociétales en travaillant d'abord les
matériaux comme le plâtre le béton puis
l'acier et enfin l'aluminium le secteur
public s'intéresse particulièrement à
son travail l'artiste est sollicité pour
réaliser des aménagements urbains et des
sculptures monumentales à guillancour
par exemple on lui connaît la place
Jacques brê du quartier des garennes
créé en
1984 alors là la pièce la plus complète
la plus aboutie c'est Guillan cour c'est
peut-être la raison de cette exposition
parce que c'est c'est le seul endroit où
quand même tout seul parce qu'ailleurs
j'ai pris des architectes j'ai pris des
paysagiste et là je me suis trouvé tout
seul j'ai tout conçu et j'ai conçu
l'ensemble je voulais absolument qu'il
ait un point fort qui était le bassin
finalement la limite le poid fort pour
moi c'est presque plus le bassin que la
sculpture par puis la sculpture elle
arrive pour faire joli à la fin quoi si
je peux diref j'étais quand même très
très content de la faire puis elle est
très très bien intégrée des sculptures
au bijoux ou encore au flacon de parfum
l'exposition présente les créations de
Manoni dans sa globalité et ses
différentes
collaborations
je vous en parlais au début de cette
émission je reçois maintenant Maxime
lpicier bonjour Maxime bonjour et Bruno
de la ville brune bonjour Bruno bonjour
messieurs vous êtes tous les deux de
jeunes président président du Young Old
Timer club c'est quoi le le J old er
club Maxime déjà c'est un nom compliqué
c'est la volonté de deux potes de
vouloir monter un club
automobile basé sur l'âge des
propriétaires des autos c'est-à-dire sur
l'âge d'avoir moins de 30 ans de montrer
qu'il y a des jeunes passionnés qui
s'intéressent à l'automobile et c'est
des jeunes qui côtoient des moins jeunes
des moins jeunes à travers un événement
par an voilà ok alors justement ces
échanges entre jeunes d'aujourd'hui et
jeunes d'autrees fois d'autres fois
d'autres fois je vais réussir à le dire
comment ça se passe Bruno alors ça se
passe très bien la demande est forte en
fait donc les entre guillemets vieilles
génération ont ce besoin de transmettre
le patrimoine leur patrimoine automobile
toutes les choses qu' qu'ils connaissent
qu's veulent vraiment le partager et les
plus jeune sont en demande d'apprendre
donc nous ce qu'on veut c'est rassembler
ces ces deux extrêmes si on peut dire et
et faire un mélange complètement
complètement formateur pour les deux
parties donc il y a une vraie
transmission de savoir exactement et
est-ce que il y a quand même un petit
conflit intergénérationnel est-ce qu'il
y a des quakques de temps en temps bah
ça peut arriver que que deux personnes
ne soient pas d'accord sur sur une auto
ou sur une façon de faire mécanique ou
autre mais la plupart du temps non non
c'est plutôt très bien accueilli auprès
de de chaque génération alors Maxime ce
weekend vous organisez deux rally c'est
ce qu'on appelle la nocturne 2014 c'est
la 3e édition cette année une édition
qui commence à compter dans le spectacle
automobile on parle déjà de la journée
de samedi est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter un peu le programme alors
grande journée puisque elle commence à
14h sur la place d'arme du château de
Versailles avec l'exposition des
voitures d'autres autos qui s'ajoutent
aussi n une soixantaine d'automobiles
présenté de 1920 à 2014 puisque ça va
des avant-guerr au supercar en passant
par l'époque un peu classique des années
60 et des Young timer concert de rock
and roll botes de paille et poules qui
vont se balader on veut essayer de
recréer une ambiance complètement
vintage et un peu festive 18h départ des
autos et là les voitures partent donc
avec un roadbook donc c'est un livret de
cheminement où inscrit le le parcours à
suivre pour plus de 100 km de rally sur
les petites routes des givelines de nuit
les voitures partent toutes les 2
minutes et on espère qu'elles vont bien
se perdre dans la région là on voit
quelques images justement à l'écran euh
le dimanche de 9h à 12h30 il y aura le
rally rambouillé versaill Bruno
exactement on les lâche pas après une
une courte nuit on les relance sur les
petites routes donc là espérons que la
météo sera avec nous mais euh donc ça va
être très tôt le matin à partir de 9h on
fait plusieurs pauses cascrout un peu
artisanale si je puis dire sur la route
pour arriver au final à à 13h sur
versaill pour un cocktail de clôture
générale pour remercier tout le monde et
et bien bien terminer le le r fa ça
exactement et on est accueilli à
Rambouillet par les rendez-vous de
laaren qui est un gros club multimarque
basé à Rambouillet et il nous
accueillent eux leurs membres nous
rejoignent donc on rentre à versaill
avec comme disait Bruno une centaine de
voitures et c'est sympa de partager
aussi avec les clubs puisque nous on
fait pas ça pour nous on fait ça pour
partager et donc des clubs se Greff à
l'événement et on parle aussi autour
d'eux donc ça c'est super sympa alors je
le disais au début de cette interview
c'est la 3e édition euh de ce de ces
rally de cette nocturne est-ce qu'il y a
des petites anecdotes que vous pouvez
nous raconter durant les les dernières
éditions je crois qu'il y en a une
l'année dernière qui est assez marqué
c'est qu'il y avait une équipe de télé
qui suivait l'événement et ils ont suivi
une voiture une Triumphe TR3 c'est la
seule voiture qui a eu un accident donc
c'était assez amusant puisque la voiture
a tapé bien l'équipage n'a rien eu c'est
rien de grave rassurez-vous il y a pas
eu de mort mais vraiment la voiture
était complètement explosée à l'avant et
l'équipe de télévision qui suivait bien
rigoler et a tout filmé je demande c'est
rien de grave parce que justement on va
venir vous suivre ce weekend TVfil 78
sera avec vous donc voilà je préfère
rassurer les équipes qui vont venir avec
vous C an à vous de choisir le bon
véhicule pour tomber sur la voiture qui
qui prendra l'arbre VO tout réside voilà
tout réside dans le toi euh je sais
qu'il existe toujours une passion pour
ces voitures de collection hein elle est
là ça on peut pas le nier mais
aujourd'hui il y a une tendance aussi
qui existe ce sont les voitures hybrides
et électriques euh est-ce que vous vous
faites un peu taper dessus sur les
doigts euh par les les écologistes avec
vous vos grosses voitures qui ne sont
pas du tout au N mais qui polluent alors
un petit peu et on aime ça euh parce que
justement c'est un c'est un débat
d'actualité l'écologie la sécurité et ça
nous tient vraiment à cœur puisque c'est
important euh mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'en France en moyenne un
véhicule de collection fait moins de 200
km par an nous on fait un rally qui doit
faire 200 km dans le weekend c'est pas
énorme et ça procure tellement de
plaisir aux gens aujourd'hui il suffit
de voir une Citroën une traction avant
une de chevaux réunis tout de suite les
ah mon grand-père avait si mon
grand-père avait ça ça ça ça procure des
émotions et je trouve queon est enfin on
voit un peu les réfion dans laquell on
est mais la les pouvoirs politiques et
les un peu les les courants de pensée
les lobby tendent à dire ah bah non les
voitures ça pollue c'est c'est c'est
c'est pas bien alors tant mieux pour l'
libride électrique mais on a encore de
belles années devant nous je dire
l'électrique avant 20 ans j'y crois pas
trop
euh mais mais voilà il faut pas toujours
mettre ça dans des catégories et surtout
c'est ces véhicules là je pense qu'
resteront dans les mémoires donc euh
malgré que que le monde soit rempli de
véhicues électriques on aura toujours
nos petites autos des années 50 à faire
tourner au garage de temps en temps le
weekend le message est passé vous teniez
à le dire voilà le message est passé on
va terminer par une note un peu plus
légère moi je vous ai préparé un petit
quiz un quiz sur les automobiles de
cinéma a est-ce que vous êtes partant
pour vous affronter Maxime Bruno j'ai
Maxime à ma droite j'ai Bruno à ma
gauche on est parti pour un petit Cu
vous ave vu j'ai sorti le petit carton
en mode Julien le perce aujourd'hui ex
pas de buzer mais c'est celui qui répond
premier qui marque le point allez on
commence tout de suite dans le corneot
le corneot un film avec Bourville Louis
funess quelle est la voiture de
Bourville de chevau bonne réponse de
Bruno un point un point attention faut
aller très vite faut aller très vite la
voiture des Ghostbusters dans SOS
fantô cadiac
heecton cadiiac ambulance 1959 en tout
cas il y a une cadiac pour l'instant
c'est quand même Bruno qui prend
l'avantage Maxime faut se réveiller la
voiture de Mad Max avec Mel Gibson un
buggy il y a un buggy effectivement mais
c'est pas ça non non non c'estousse non
non non non non on a une photo on va la
montrer c'est la Ford Falcon XB coupé je
crois qu'on a une photo qui va
s'afficher la voilà vous pouvez la voir
ou non elle est super cette voiture
allez là c'est une question de rapidité
la voiture de taxi euh 46 Peugeot 406 ça
y est il l'a dit le point le point est
pour Maxime la voiture de retour vers le
futur une deloréane deloran DEL laoréane
DMC12 bravo bravo mais c'est Maxime qui
a été le plus rapide la voiture de
Bullit tiens avec Steve mcquein voitureb
67 plus rapide que moi 68 68 mais je
quand même je donne le point à Maxime il
le mérite la voiture de
starkych
euh si c'est une Lincoln non c'est une
c'est pas une Lincoln rouge voiture
rouge voiture rouge avec une bande
blanche on s'en souvient c'est une c'est
une Ford
Mercury a une
aussioro grand Torino Torino allez
vraiment à la fin du décomte la voiture
de casino royal James Bond n Martin DBS
il est très fort il est très fort Bruno
là il faut y aller maintenant c'est
maintenant bon la voiture de Braquage à
l'italienne mini a Cooper trop facile
très fort très fort je sais pas où on en
est au niveau des points mais je crois
que Bruno est en train de remonter la
voiture de
K2000 fameuse kit ouais c'est on salue
d'ailleurs David asselov c'est une ça
commence par un P pon Pontiac quoi fireb
firebd voilà il est pour Bruno le point
la voiture de Drive avec chevrelet il y
en a deux il y en a deux là je sais pas
ce qu'il a il y a une chevrolete ouais
mais il y a une mergess japonaise on en
parle pas sur le plate Chevrolet et Ford
les modèles euh allez on tente on tente
quelque chose Ford allez Chevrolet
Malibu Ford Mustang désolé il faut aller
vite la voiture de Fast and Furious de
feu Paul Walker une Ford escorte non non
c'est une japonaise n GTR c'est une
Nissan mais c'est pas oui Nissan Skyline
GTR ou bravo Maxime allez il en reste
deux pour terminer pour terminer de VI
de vieilles voiture je pense que c'est
Maxime qui va gagner mais on va
peut-être faire compter la la question
la dernière question un peu plus la
voiture de Colombo je sais pas une DS
non mais c'est une voiture française 403
Peugeot 403 ah pas mal allez la dernière
la dernière la ouais elle est à l'écran
la voiture regardez on la voit la
voiture de Colombo la dernière vaut 1
million de points la der la question
attention la voiture de Louis la
Brocante une estafette c'est une
estafette mais il me faut le modèle ça
suffit pas renult c'est Renault
staffette c'est pas Renault stafette
c'est pas Renault c'est pas r hy euh un
tube hy le Citroën type H bravo bravo
c'est donc Bruno qui remporte avec
100liion3 points contre 5 points bien
joué bien joué bon voilà la dernière
question mais en tout cas bravo à vous
deux bravo à vous deux vous êtes de vra
connaen samedi à partir de 14h30 sur
Parville de la place d'arme au pied du
château pour un verre de vin chaud et
venir danser recabili merci beaucoup
Maxime merci beaucoup Bruno à bientôt on
va enchaîner avec le reste de
l'actualité est-ce que vous connaissez
le CRAV Maga est-ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose le CRAV Maga c'est un
sport de combat non ah c'est pas loin
c'est pas loin en fait c'est Nathalie
renard qui est instructrice de CRAV Maga
à Guy enc et surtout elle est la
première femme diplômée de France dans
sa fédération portrait d'une sportive
passionnée qui inculque des techniques
de défense acc
àous anony et
Elod allez on lève les genou il y a 5
ans Nathalie renard souhaite retrouver
une activité sportive et découvre le
CRAV Maga ancienne gymnaste de haut
niveau ses qualités physiques lui ont
vite permis de s'adapter au techniques
de combat au bout seulement de 3 saisons
l'élève passe le diplôme d'instructeur
je trouvais qu'il y avait pas assez de
femme au cours voilà
et il y en avait quelquesunes et c'est
vrai que quand en discutant à
l'extérieur de de cette activité
sportive euh beaucoup de femmes
réagissaient en disant oh non Benon
j'aimerais bien essayer mais ça me fait
un peu peur non c'est trop violent non
c'est Nathalie la première femme
française diplômée de sa fédération et
elle a fait des émules puisque deux
autres instructrices l'ont suivi en
l'espace de 5 ans elle a vu les attentes
autour du CRAV Maga évoluer quand j'ai
commencé le crave les élèves venaient
pour effectivement se
défouler
activité je dirais comme une autre
presque et de plus en plus aujourd'hui
nous on pose la questions mais voilà
pourquoi vous voulez faire du CRAV Maga
mais en fait des fois on a même pas
besoin de poser la question les gens
viennent et nous expliquent voilà moi il
m'est arrivé ça et j'aimerais bien
savoir un petit peu me défendre et
cetera utilisé à l'origine par les
Forces Spéciales israéliennes le but du
CRAV magaga n'est pas de faire des
élèves des combattants hors père mais
plutôt leur inculquer des techniques
d'attaque dééfense permettant de se
sortir d'une situation difficile sa et
SAU il y a un peu trop d'agression donc
vaut mieux savoir se défendre avant de
se faire agresser en fait rien que
prendre par le coup direct ou à la fin
prendre avec le coup et avec l'arme et
traîner par terre l'agresseur ça c'est
bon ça marche en 2 ans les effectifs du
club de CRAV magaga de guillancour ont
doublé passant de 50 à 105 adhérents en
2014 impressionnant si photograp au
grand cœur renouvelle cette année
l'opération solidaire une séance photo
contre un don Frédéric gras photographe
à hencour participe au projet sourier
pour Asmae jusqu'au 2 février Aurélia
debici et Jonathan villman six tu es
prête tu me regardes poussin 1 2 3 courz
ok pour la 3e année six photographe
réparti sur toute la France organise une
opération solidaire en faveur des plus
démunis l'opération intitulée sourill
pour Asmae se déroule jusqu'au 2 février
on a mis en place ce projet pour aider
l'association de sœur Emmanuel qui
s'appelle Asmae le but c'est de que les
personnes qui participent réalisent un
don et en échange nous on offre notre
temps pour leur offrir une séance photo
qui habituellement est payante tous les
ans nous ce qui nous fait vivre c'est
les familles et c'est les enfants donc
on voulait absolument rendre aux enfants
qui ont moins de chance que d'autres et
à certaines familles aussi qui sont dans
la difficulté euh cette chance que que
nous on a euh et donc du coup on a
décidé de faire cette cette opération
pour essayer de les aider à notre petit
niveau quoi une vraie séance photo
professionnelle d'une heure et dem en
échange d'un don libre et toute la
famille est convié à prendre la pause
pour la bonne cause participer à cette
action solidaire pour moi bah c'était
une opportunité de pouvoir donner un peu
de de soi et de se faire plaisir en
famille donc j'ai j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion et euh si on nous offrait une
séance photo et si en même temps je peux
je peux je peux contribuer à aider pour
cette association je me suis dit
pourquoi pas vous restez debout
l'opération se termine par un concours
la meilleure photo de chaque famille
sera mise sur la page Facebook du
photographe celle qui remportera un
maximum de j'aes ira en finale pour
tenter de gagner trois tirages grand
format ce 78 weekend est pratiquement
terminé un petit coup d'œil sur les
idées sorties de ce weekend dans dans
l'agglomération 5 pour terminer la philo
d'an Sophie accompagné d'Anne Sophie
deux jeunes philosophes en herb vont
débattre du thème pourquoi on meurt le
but c'est d'apprendre à réfléchir
ensemble sans que la parole de l'adulte
soit souveraine et c'est samedi à
staminé de 15h30 à 16h le bal des
intouchables c'est la troupe des
colporteurs qui s'interroge sur les
thèmes de la marginalité et de la
différence en utilisant tout le
potentiel des disciplines du cirque
sensible drôle et acrobatique c'est à la
base de loisirs de5qu1 en Yveline samedi
et dimanche voilà c'est tout pour ce 78
weekend nous on se retrouve lundi pour
le reste de l'actualité avec le 78 lactu
de Wilfried Richy et le 78 sport
d'Anthony res un excellent weekend à
tous sur TVfil 78
salut